hi everyone I'm here at the University
of Sydney today I've got one familiar
face Peter over here how's it going and
this is Gabe and Liam okay um so
everyone here is interested in I guess
physics physics education and we've got
some experiments set up for you so the
first one we have here you might hear
something in the background is the
vandergraph generator so
this is I guess all about static charge
and electricity so you know you can see
a bit of a discharge of electricity
between these two balls maybe Peter or
someone else has set this up tell me
what your explanation of it is well so
the basic idea is that um remember that
experiment that you did hopefully in
primary school maybe High School where
you take a plastic rod or a ruler and
you rub it with a piece of cloth a piece
of felt and then you put it next to some
water or next to uh like a tissue or
some paper or whatever and that stream
of water is slightly attracted towards
that a ruler that is basically uh it's
separating the charges
right to create you know the a pull
right so that's kind of what's Happening
Here there's a
one part of this contraption is becoming
really strongly
charge and the other one isn't as
strongly charged and then it Sparks
across the air it's like an electric
potential yeah there's a gap as a rule
of thumb every centimeter that a sparch
arcs across air is between 15 000 to 30
000 volts depending on kind of the
humidity and all those kind of things so
that is 10 or 15 centimeter Gap we'll
take care that's a lot of volts so I'm
gonna do the math quick 300
[Music]
000 volts on a good day
for about 30 centimeter spark today is
not a good day but we have had it do 30
centimeters before which is
um
so you're saying there's 300 000 volts
and there's a thing here and there's a
lot of us around and there's this foam
thing on the floor
probably next thing we're going to end
up doing so if you can safely Stand
country this and build up a lot of
charge and we could see hopefully some
interesting things happening
but so this is so that I can safely
stand here and touch this what if I just
touched it
like what would happen to me it would
hurt yeah yeah so instead of discharging
into the grounding ball there which is
nicely collected throughout the ground
so it doesn't matter you would be
grounded okay
[Music]
okay so there was an idea thrown around
that I don't know you've probably seen
in cartoons that when you hold one of
these your hair starts to stand on end
um because I guess each strand of your
hair has the same charge and like they
start to repel each other and individual
hairstyles
I have quite long hair I guess so I can
try and take mine out and see if it does
anything on the generator my suspicion
is that it made my hair would be too
heavy like each individual strand I
think maybe it'll work best on fine hand
maybe you guys can try after me but I've
never tried on one of these since I've
had one well you've got a traitic
science we've got to do an experiment
yeah
and bring back my classic science of
long hair series
that's a good 15 at the moment so that's
probably around 4.50 I actually have a
wooden roller but it's got metal
detained so yeah
you can feel it sort of a track when you
stuck
stuff
I'm not moving at all no it does have a
good bounce yeah that's so cool okay all
righty anything I want to demonstrate
our eye marks first you're up first
I'd maybe take your watch off
it's normally totally safe but yeah I'm
more worried about breaking your watch
than having you okay you're discharging
it I'm just charging at the mount so
what you'll need to do now
so in order to build charge and look
okay now but yeah both hands
it's good at the moment I'm gonna now
take the Earth off yeah
so you should feel anything I don't feel
anything okay but you can see that yeah
yeah give it
and in particular oh my God that's
amazing
that's so cool
cameraman how is it
are any of the longest strands like yeah
to push out a little bit yeah
this shouldn't hurt you no you shouldn't
except I might be able to do it
if you don't mind
all right City can you see that yeah
yeah you can see it a little bit
is that a Charged road
perspect so it should be completely so
the same yeah so it shouldn't be you
wouldn't know otherwise oh my God that's
so cool let's have a look at the back
yeah that hair strand right there that
one's flat I'm not flying off
the back that's so amazing holy crap so
you know this isn't the biggest
vandergraph dinner out there I've ever
seen no but they're like a much bigger
ones that exist where the charge buildup
would be a lot more yeah yeah so I mean
I don't think I can get all my hair
standing on end with this one but maybe
with a bigger one seriously so
impressive
I mean that is still quite as happy that
the picture yeah that's amazing
all right and you can see it's clearly
affecting the top yet yeah
I have now which is uh slightly scary is
how conductive is hair
if I touch one of your strands of hair
it's cuddling isn't it
think so but if you do touch the ones at
the back yeah these ones here okay
oh it's slightly it's like look it's
pulling towards me
oh that's pulling away that's going
towards so you're exchanging charge
today yeah yeah whoa you're stripping
your electrons I'll release myself from
this without getting in there
Toby do you feel that I can feel that we
have a spot
so just hands straight up and as you
step off don't touch anyone or anything
touching the ground you're here to drop
straight down there's all the characters
metal
oh my God that was awesome very good
nice all right see
yeah
yeah okay well it's pretty long how
about someone with shorter hair try to
Peter you should go
every time there's still a tiny spark
let's go all right
yeah Toby uh this might be your
experience as well every time I do this
there's this um like I know the physics
and I know that it's safe and I trust
the equipment and I trust Liam and I
teach like a stupid amount of the years
and years of education I have but it
still feels weird but it still feels
scary and slightly wrong I remember this
was like one of these
[Music]
how safe I would be on the charges
um so yeah I had to get up there blind
and do it okay I was fine but yeah
yeah I can't see it I know I know yeah
I'll show you yeah it's definitely
standing up here
was down here before can you see you oh
wow okay it's pretty good yeah
that's fine no I but I feel I feel so
you can actually take your hands off and
put it back whoa wait whoa yeah whoa why
is it making that noise but the Crackle
the discharge
oh you'll have a different potential
between there and there yeah
as opposed to your head so you can
actually don't do it yet but you can
take your hands off for a little bit and
then put it back on for like a few
seconds look at that with your hair drop
you're doing that yeah
because the charge is going to you not
to me well see I'm now I'm acting like a
lightning rod
stealing guy from yeah
all right so what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to let go of my hands on there
I'm going to put them back on yeah
because your card could be the same
right so you the reason you're not
getting shock is because you're the same
charge as it so when you take your hands
off you should stay relatively the same
chart I could do insulated from the
ground and that's not going to build up
too much more Chuck so you'll take it
off okay put it back on and you
shouldn't get shot oh that's the whole
thing of the electric potential yeah
sure sure I understand
I just want to hope it's like you know
so so a year ago there was a show with
Todd Sampson called life on the line
and like I thought the premise
originally was kinda lame and then like
genuinely when he did a bungee jump with
with a phone book like connecting the
two elastic wires I was like man this
dude gets it like this is actually
insane it's like one thing to know you
know the theory and the the tests of it
and then the other thing is to actually
bungee jump with the phone book so a lot
of faith in the map right yeah yeah all
right so three two one one
three out
see the head does not drop back because
he's still on yeah I just sparked across
the table it will jump into the table
Yeah because that's yeah so I get off
I'll discharge and then we first bump
again okay we'll do it all right
all right
yeah hit the table you'll stop a bit
[Laughter]
oh so good
physics am I right in science guys good
science
no I'm not sure if that was the spot or
that was the actual life yeah
it was perfectly time for the spark did
we not turn the lights off no no no that
was absolutely not time sometimes it
takes out electrical stuff like we know
we've done too much when that clock up
the back just goes into gibberish and
the lecture flies well if these were
down
yeah the cloths I come out it's cool
it's been real we're done here
physics for the day yes okay so we were
rummaging in this cupboard looking for
some more experiments to use and Peter
pointed out this strangely melted piece
of metal and he told me that this is a
lightning rod yeah it's a lightning rod
that actually was at the University of
Sydney and it was hit
um by lightning and then all the current
around it basically created a strong
magnetic field that basically pulled
itself together
yeah so it deformed from like a solid
like the pipe that it is with a hollow
opening as you can see and like the pipe
shot itself and closed itself off there
pinched itself together so it's actually
cold uh the pinch effect and there's a
demonstration of this here and we're not
doing it because there's one of the
Transformers is broken and we don't want
to blow anything up if you put current
into here it basically does that yeah it
doesn't happen in this building yeah all
right let's go do some more experiments
yeah